lo haremos esta lucha
cueste lo que cuece en México
aproximadamente 12 millones de personas
carecen de acceso al agua potable la
sequía que se vive en el norte del país
es severa aquí en el centro también la
escasez de agua ha provocado cortes en
el suministro pero sin duda Quienes más
lo padecen Quienes más sufren esto que
denominan catástrofe hídrica son los
pueblos originarios las comunidades
indígenas por eso se han dado cita hoy
aquí para marchar en Paseo de la Reforma
en esto que denominan la marcha contra
el despojo del agua y por el derecho a
la vida Don Faustino De dónde viene
usted y Qué es la problemática que está
padeciendo vengo de Santiago mezquitlán
municipio de Amealco Estado de Querétaro
el problemático es el saqueo el
sobrevaloración de los precios este la
explotación del agua hacia los políticos
y a los este poderes económicos
Gracias Así es protestan de Querétaro de
Puebla contra la sobreexplotación de los
mantos acuíferos por parte de empresas
transnacionales y no nada más aquí en la
capital del país también en otros puntos
de la república se manifiestan en
Mexicali Baja California contra la
cerveceras en Puebla contra las empresas
de agua precisamente contra la industria
Automotriz y todo en el marco de este
día mundial del agua que
continuará también con un meeting en
otros plazas públicas y también jornadas
culturales